bonjour à vos amours premières et
j'espère pas la dernière on se
retrouvera tous les dimanches de 18h15 à
19h je ne vous parle pas de la suite des
opérations vous n'avez qu'à suivre le
guide est resté avec nous jusqu'à la fin
je serai toujours en tout cas tous les
dimanches en compagnie d'un invité
aujourd'hui mon invité une réputation de
séducteur mais il a horreur de ça je
vous préviens il a une réputation de don
juan mais ils crient au malentendu il
est plus fregoli que mythe il multiplie
les régissent et les expériences
anti-star antibourgeois il est toujours
ce qu'il pense il aime déranger et c'est
ce qu'on va voir
michel piccoli
c'est vous en plus je suis contente
michel ça me fait bizarre parce que j'ai
toujours monsieur piccoli mais je vous
appeler michel ça me fait plaisir parce
que si vous préférez oui c'est la
saint-michel aujourd'hui bas très bon
ami sean fait michel merci beaucoup
comme je viens de dire
le public vous prend pour un
professionnel la séduction c'est un
malentendu c'est une erreur vous êtes
faudra joue près par rapport à ça que
l'horreur professionnels de la séduction
tout le monde a sa séduction tout le
monde a besoin de séduction tout le
monde aime la séduction tout le monde à
une sélection mais les professionnels
des solutions ce sont des anti séduisant
ça c'est comme ça non bien on part en
sucette viseur on va apprendre à vous
connaître un petit peu plus dans ce
qu'on appelle nous un portrait robot
morpho psycho un regarde un morceau vrai
psychologue serait en scrutant votre
sourire si vous mentez comme un
arracheur de dents en évaluant votre
appendice nasal si vous menez les gens
par le bout du nez et en faisant autour
du globe si vous avez l'oreille en coin
surtout il répondrait d'emblée à cette
question fondamentale est de 1,10 l'été
qui sourit à la vie ou un rétracter qui
n'en pensent pas moins
au vu de votre foi incliné de rétracter
latéral vous êtes un voyeur un audacieux
mais aussi un téméraire homme
d'intérieur vous aspirez aux émotions
fortes
homme de ménage méthodique vous
dépoussiérer savamment les idées reçues
sous le sourcil épais façon très diffuse
un signe du temps de sérieux et de
pragmatisme
on devine l'extra terriens qui
s'enracine dans la nature humaine pour
devenir ce comédien agricole comme vous
dites votre façon de faire campagne
pas besoin de sortir de saint cyr pour
en déduire que l'oeil abriter wisches
elle reflète votre péché mignon la farce
tranquille et votre ya de velours en dit
long sur votre goût pour la séduction et
ses fruits de la passion
ben voyons que dire de vos maxillaire si
ce n'est qu'ils sont sans doute la
preuve que vous ne marchez pas vos mots
que votre bouche plutôt fine et dessiner
synonyme de raffinement de travail bien
fait de goût pour la belle langue et de
baisers volés peu vote n'est ma foi
normal projeter en avant l inverse des
faciès de pékinois sent bon le contact
social agrémenté par un globule plutôt
rond qui respire la bienveillance et la
tendresse
ajoutez à cela un air détaché qui vous
donnent l'air attachons des mains fines
puissante qui révèle parfaitement votre
violon dingue dans vous savez jouer de
la corde sensible avec une persévérance
digne des plus grands obsédé gestuelle
enfin votre silhouette août imposante
mais aériennes parce que couronnais
d'une auréole de cheveux nuageux vous
donne des airs de chevalier savants et
de petits princes sans rire à la main
visible
bref j'ai pensé un instant vous
rebaptisé compte des sex symbol de vos
débuts
mais puisque le clown est un peu votre
définition de l'acteur quoi de plus
normal au vu de vos fous rires planqué
devant air de pierrot silencieux et de
votre absolue fidélité de vous appeler
dorénavant monsieur loyal tout
simplement
[Musique]
voilà je vous ai entendu rire sur le pdg
situer là l'a bien dit gestuelle c'est
très beau et de gestuelle magnifique
il ya aussi qu'une chose qui m'a fait
rire ses comptes des sexes mais parce
qu'à un moment il paraît vous avez voulu
changer de nom car j'étais un coup de
théâtre
je jouais une scène qui avait trait à la
reine d'angleterre et de son bel amant
le comte d'essex et je vais demander
est-ce qu'il faut pas changer de nom
pour devenir acteur j'en attendais
depuis douze pol mois que s'arrêter bien
pour mes joueurs et gêné s'appelait et
c'est que c'est un peu fort de café
michel des sexes oui c'était bien pour
la première dans sa tête comme celle des
sexes n'est pas de particules c'était un
mais chez michel et sexy sexe oui oui un
peu trop téléphonée nous oui pour
surtout pour vous si vous n'avez pas
quand on vous disait en général non
alors vous aimez bien multiplie les
expériences les aventures je parle
professionnels professionnels
par contre alors attention tout ce que
j'ai eu sur vous en amour vous dit que
l'amour ne peut survivre que par et avec
la fidélité oui j'en suis persuadé non
pas pour me mettre en exemple mais j'ai
bien regardé les autres vivre la quête
d'amour est une des plus grandes quêtes
de notre existence mais quand on ne
trouve pas ou alors quand on a trouvé
qu'on s'est trompé et qu'il faut
recommencer
c'est qu'il faut être tragique les
séparations ce tragique les
recommencements sont en difficulté mais
vous dit toujours que si on a envie de
trahir il vaut mieux partir
oui je crois que des kia trahison il ya
départ et vous avez souvent vous
appartient vous êtes souvent partie mais
jamais trahi j'ai été trahi et j'ai
trahi je suis comblé donc tout ce que je
vous ai dit c'est de la théorie tendance
que c'est la théorie ce que vous avez
dit non c'est de la pratique
je vous ai demandé d'amener un petit peu
notre univers dans ce dans ce décor
parce qu'il est tout nouveau alors on
avait envie de l'habiter de choses que
vous aimez maven d'une canne
oui pourquoi ça je sentimentale la peine
de mort si je suis gentil mental plus
oui oui je suis choquée moi je suis pas
du tout nostalgique
j'ai horreur de la nostalgie mais
sentimentale oui à cette can était la
can de mon père
et puis les morts c'est devenu la can de
ma mère et puis elle est morte alors
j'ai gardé cette can et je me dis qu'un
jour ça sera ma canne
sega toys est oui mais où va l est à
votre nou lé pas un matin là que je la
fasse trafic et ne sais pas si on peut
allonger une canne et la locomotive à la
locomotive c'est toute une histoire
d'une locomotive en quelque sorte
historique
je préparais le tournage d'un film en
albanie ne s'est pas tourné en albanie
et pour cause c'était encore sous le
régime de ce cher dictateur envers aux
jo et j'ai acheté à tirana cette
locomotive qui étaient fabriqués en
chine achetées en albanie et la boîte
était est écrit en anglais dessus j'ai
une grande tendresse pour cette
locomotive qui marche d'ailleurs on la
fera peut-être marché en fin d'émission
qui a été acheté
vendu par les chinois à tirana et acheté
par un occidental à tirana pour la 2eme
entendu de gong joachim terre voilà
normalement le gong fait stop on arrête
et on pioche une question parce que
pendant trois fois dans cette émission
vous allez devoir peser que chez une
petite question est y répondre en disant
la vérité toute la vérité rien que la
vérité
cupidon cupidon en écoute michel piccoli
avez vous déjà battu une amoureuse
non ça a été rapide la réponse vous en
êtes sûr sûr jamais porté la main non
même pour des raisons perverse noms des
réseaux perverse oui mais sans violence
oui ça suffit avec les sentiments pardon
avec l'assentiment de la dame
il ya fois il faut quelquefois
convaincre oui c'est dur c'est amusant
merci on va tout de suite retrouvé une
autre partie du décor pour la partie
magazine
[Musique]
voilà juste avant de commencer le
magazine michel piccoli je voulais juste
revenir un petit peu en arrière ça vous
gêne pas question qu'on vous pose comme
ça parce que vous êtes souvent j'aime
poser ce genre de questions qui les
dérange et qui les gêne
oui mais ne vous gênez pas non plus à
mon endroit adéquat à mon endroit j'ai
pas comment aussi ces jeunes et oui elle
écrira ses parties de votre personnage
vous aimez bien provoquer vous aimez
bien déranger en tout cas brusque un peu
j'aime bien brusquer et j'aime bien être
brusqué aussi je voudrais qu'on sort est
non pas sur une autre triste pour
l'instant mais je voulais avant
d'oublier la fin d'émission dire et je
pense que ça va vous faire plaisir vous
aviez quelqu'un dans votre vie qui était
pouvoir directeur de conscience un
maître à penser
un frère un père c'était andré de
richaud nous sommes le 29 septembre
c'est la date d'anniversaire de sa mort
comment fait une émission sur l'amour je
trouve c'était celle de las vegas et le
samovar 70 68
merci de me le rappeler parce que je
vais aucune idée de la date précise et
pourtant c'est un être qui a compté
beaucoup pour moi pour beaucoup d'autres
d'ailleurs un très grand poète maudit
oui ans il est encore lui il est encore
édité il n'est pas complètement oublié
un très grand écrivain très gras poète
un un très grand seigneur un très grand
mendiants un très grand alcoolique
voilà je voulais avoir cette petite
pensée pour lui en veux te compagnie
aujourd'hui 29 septembre voilà comment
s'est tout de suite par votre votre coup
de foudre je vous ai demandé de chercher
dans les jours qui précèdent quelque
chose qui vous a marqué quelque chose
qui vous a ému ça pourrait être quoi
j'ai tellement de choses mais on peut
parler d'une chose c'est de serre faty
ce prisonnier marocain qui a fait 17 ans
de prison qui vient d'être libéré alors
que c'est ce qui explique cette son pays
soit disant brésilien bon c'est un
opposant au régime actuel ne parlons pas
de sa bataille politique
on pourrait en parler longtemps de
gauche elle stalinien oui qui n'a pas
été stalinien qui a été qui a cru en
staline et qui a été trahi par staline
qu'est ce qui vous a touché la somme
tout cela aussi bien ceux qui le
détestaient que ceux qui l'aimaient
touché c'est quand on lui pose une
question très délicate surtout la
réponse
qu'est ce qui vous a manqué le plus
en prison il aurait pu raconter à tas de
choses douloureuses pour lui il a dit
une chose merveilleuse idée ce qui m'a
manqué le plus c'est de ne pas voir des
enfants
ça vous a touché d'autant que magnifique
un monsieur qui pourraient raconter ses
douleurs qui pourraient raconter son
combat 10 il m'a manqué des enfants
jouent à thabo il le disait une façon
très simple ils n'essayaient pas de de
faire un mot on va vous montrer
maintenant un petit magazine artistique
de la semaine évidemment qu'ils portent
une belle traduction de l'amour de son
olympe venus surveille une rivale glenn
close diva binoclarde bel organe qui
mène à la baguette
niels arestrup captif du chant de la
sirène
la tentation de vénus présentait à la
mostra de venise
actuellement sur vos écrans il est
génial parce que je n'ai désherbants les
aventuriers de l'orgasme retrouver
langage et bruitages dévastateur pour
revisiter les bonheurs et les erreurs
des choses de la vie
une fois n'est pas coutume couple occupe
actuellement le théâtre du splendid
et
au pays des jioi rolls et signalent un
nouveau rôdeur kidnappeur de lola
[Musique]
les corps se déshumaniser se confondent
sous le pinceau de cet artiste de
manhattan pour qui la douleur amoureuse
n'arrivent pas toujours où on l'attend
là où il n'y a pas de surprise
il n'y a pas de plaisir costa by exposé
à paris jusqu'au 4 octobre
[Musique]
pour ramener au bercail rhett butler
scarlett o'hara peut compter sur les
créations de sonia rykiel qui s'est
amusé à billets ou plutôt à déshabiller
l'héroïne de margaret mitchell
je regarderai les toilettes de scarlett
en les faisant beaucoup plus d'être
simple et que je les ouvrirait tous
devant j'aurais eu envie de voir ces
gens
donc j'aurais fait les mêmes robes mais
ouverte devant est finalement assez
perverse
parce que elle et la perversité même
mais j'ai fait une robe que je vous ai
apporté là il ya quatre ou cinq ans tout
est fait par hasard comme ça et
aujourd'hui hier en la voyant sur nous
sur ma fille
j'étais très étonné parce que j'ai
trouvé que c'était tout effet scarlett
d'aujourd'hui
mais oui scarlett o'hara et rhett butler
sont enfin de retour la suite d'autant
en emporte le vent vient de paraître
[Musique]
elle est un petit peu gonflé quand même
sonia rykiel trouve scarlett perverse et
vous oui effectivement que je crois que
tout le monde est pervers exprimez vous
non mais j'écoute est votre regard
la perversité est considérée comme un
péché comme une tare ou comme avis je
crois que la perversité fait partie d'un
aux arcanes
c'est un antidote contre la banalité
c'est ce sont des secrets ce sont des
approches qui font un jeu admirable
entre les êtres et pas seulement la
perversité amoureux c'est pas du tout ça
tous les rapports ou syndic tous les
êtres humains sont pervers vous avez
envie qu'elle retrouva jamais son raid
butler ou qu'elle soit séparée de lui
qu'on n'en parle plus la moitié des
femmes voudraient qu'ils se retrouvent
vous voyez que tout ça est très pervers
oui mais vous qu'est ce que vous en
pensez que c'était moi je souhaite
qu'elle continue à nous faire rêver avec
la de butler ou un autre une histoire de
femmes ça pour vous scarlett de ces
femmes qui achètent ce livre point final
les hommes
je crois que les femmes le lisais que
les hommes en rêve
oui viviane legg avait été lancé loges
d'après ce que j'ai lu c'est peut-être
faux mais les images de villes et niang
au moment où vous jouez vous jouiez
mademoiselle julie je vous le jure et un
tout petit théâtre théâtre bleus excepté
le théâtre babylone j'ai pas jean marie
serreau nous jouions mademoiselle julie
et je sais par quel miracle ont été
invités vialli et laurence olivier nous
étions dans nos petits souliers
on avait acheté péniblement avec nous
pauvres bourse une bouteille de
champagne au cas où
parce qu'ils avaient dit nous ne voulons
nous l'avons jamais dans les coulisses
et puis peut-être eût-il été content
sûrement les voilà t'y pas qui arrive
dans la coulisse et voient arriver
il ya ni et laurence olivier en
coulisses ça fait un choc alors été très
elle parlait beaucoup c'est une femme
très extraverti très c'était une allumés
comme on dit vulgairement personne
magnifique
le silence est ce que vous pensez qu'on
peut la remplacer il est peut-être prévu
une adaptation de scarlett pour le
cinéma la lecture emploi stable mais qui
pourrait la remplacer l'actuel bercy
jamais personne qu'il faut pas non
terminé non ça serait une reçu un remake
ça s'appelle moi j'appelle ça plus
légalement une resucée on va loin je
vous ai demandé une scène d'amour que
vous aimez particulièrement vous m'avez
dit une scène dans le bel deux jours de
bunuel
oui alors c'est l'histoire d'un couple
effectivement contre scènes d'amour oui
l expérience justement pour une scène de
perversité et c'est une scène très moral
sur l'amour d'un couple lui ils
s'adorent mais lui ne s'occupaient pas
d'elle donc alors but d'assouvir ses
fantasmes
elle va finir à cause de vous le méchant
qui lui avait donné l'adresse de la
maison close de luxe où elle peut se
rendre mais c'était pas méchant parce
que c'est un très grand respectueux de
son mari de cette dame qui a des
extravagances et il ya le faire une
leçon de morale dans une chambre de
maison de rendez vous et plutôt que de
lui offrir
je ne sais pas ce qu'on peut imaginer
lui offre du chocolat montaury magie
tout vu ou plutôt il dit bah écoutez
vous offrirai du chocolat à votre mari
mais beaucoup de chocolat
souvent les hommes n'ont pas le temps de
s'occuper de leur famille ils les
prennent trop pour des accessoires non
pas comme des êtres essentiel c'est un
petit peu le propos de ce film c'est le
vôtre aussi
aujourd'hui de tout temps je crois je
crois que en effet l'un des défauts des
hommes c'est de ne pas concéder à leurs
femmes comme un essentiel mais de les
considérer comme une présence pratique
il vous arrive quelquefois de refuser un
film pour rester chez vous vous occupez
d'elle quand j'étais très jeune acteur
c'est un métier on est complètement
passionné aux aguets d'un engagement on
75 % de votre vie c'est son métier est
un jeune j'ai sûrement commis des
erreurs
je pensais plus à mon métier qu'à
d'autres choses
ou que des personnes qui m'était proche
mais j'ai appris à vivre si je puis dire
et maintenant oui je m'arrange pour être
ne pas être seulement sur les écrans ou
sur la scène très bien parti
j'allais dire aucune chance de rester
dur j'avais dit on n'a pas dépassé c'est
génial voilà la petite question qui
tombe très bien vous ne prenez pas peur
il dit juste dans la question que ça ne
va casanova jah fakoly vous êtes donc
déjà dit que vous étiez un bon coup or
non franchement je n'oserais répondent
se fait de l'indiscrétion pour une
personne qui aurait eu le l'amabilité de
me le dire et aussi ça serait très
prétentieux de ma part de vous répondre
oui c'est très dangereux de répondre non
donc je ne répondrai pas c'est comme ça
j'en passe et michel michel c'est
toujours la vérité
oui mais permettez-moi de de m'abstenir
asia jeu vous permet de vous abstenir de
piccoli on va appeler dix huit jean
teulé que vous connaissez et qui va
venir nous rejoindre vous apporter les
bons plans de semaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais voilà les petits qui t'attendait
alors vous parliez de bons coups
monsieur michel est ce que vous savez
mais c'est bien monsieur michel n'ont
pas suffi est-ce que vous savez qu'ils
étaient victor noir parce que lui
c'était vraiment un bon coup pour dent
c'est un monsieur qui depuis un siècle
il ya un tas de fans qui vont sur lui
valade monsieur victor noir c'était un
type qui est mort à 22 en 1870 il était
journaliste il avait dit du mal de
napoléon un cousin napoléon la provoquer
en duel et la tuer et il se passe un
truc bizarre sur cette tombe c'est que
depuis voilà il est au père lachaise et
les femmes stériles depuis depuis un
siècle vont sur la tombe de victor noir
pour se guérir de leur stérilité
alors on va voir la tombe justement donc
voilà il se voyait c'est un gisant donc
c'est un monsieur qui est couché c'est
donc l'acteur noir et regardez la pointe
de ses bottes
là elle envoyait à pain des bottes qui
est complètement lustres et il ya la
bosse du sexe et puis le visage à savoir
le nez la bouche et le menton parce que
depuis un siècle
il ya une légende qui dit que les femmes
qui se couche sur qui se s'assoit sur
son visage sur son sexe et alors quand
ils sont assis sur le sexe ou bien se
tenir
donc à sa trappe aux bottes et ben ça
guérit de la série exactement
si c'est pour tomber dans le gravier la
nuit et alors être ça le matin ou le
soir et se guérit de la sérénité alors à
priori ça semble une idiotie mais j'ai
appris un truc c'est que en fait la
sérénité c'est souvent très
psychologique
ce qui fait que par exemple dans les
sociétés primitives il ya des totems des
déesses qu'ils sont les déesses de
fécondité et il ya aussi dans les
centres qui guérit sa stérilité
il s'arrange pas ce que ça coûte très
cher de faire une sorte qu'ils aient une
queue longue devant cet autre que les
gens doivent attendre deux mois deux
mois et demi les femmes pour pour ce
faire guy réseau ça et à partir du
moment où elles sont inscrites dans la
file d'attenté
eh ben elle tombe souvent enceinte et il
ya aussi les femmes qui adoptent des
enfants qui adopte des enfants à partir
en oisans adopté le môme et ben
c'est là qu'elles sont enceintes qu'est
ce qu'ils font de l'enfant adoptée sais
pas qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qu'ils font
de l'enfant adoptée vu que du coup elle
vous en voulez un se retrouver avec deux
donc c'est une histoire vraie c'est
complètement vrai c'est au père lachaise
métropole un père lachaise 92e division
donc ça c'est l'adresse et les femmes
sert il devrait y aller parce que ça
parce que ça comblera le déficit de la
sécurité sociale
voilà un beau gâchis il ya aussi des
hommes stériles
oui non mais là c'est seulement les
femmes c'est ça sera la semaine
prochaine les hommes ne vont pas se
frotter non non non non non non non
parce que vraiment c'est victor noir
sont secs seront mélasse voilà comme une
bonne question quand on parle stérilité
sur la femme ce qui est stérile l'homme
j'avais à bercy si si mais milazzo
victoire méritée l'homme sait chaque
beaucoup plus que la femme laffont 9
la femme aux dires du maire ce choc de
jeunes orgueil mais la femme se choque
encore plus profondément pas son
deuxième alors deuxième chose c'est une
affiche une affiche de spectacle c'est
donc ça c'était le bon plan de la
semaine la tombe de victor noir père
lachaise et là c'est le spectacle qu'on
vous conseille à vos amours ça se passe
du 3 au 8 octobre à la cigale et vous
voyez ça c'est une chanteuse qui est nu
voilà donc mais cette chanteuse si vous
avez raté la femme à barbe à la foire du
trône
il faut aller voir cette chanteuse qui
s'appelle sapho parce qu'elle a la plus
grande toison pubienne du monde et cette
chanteuse donc ils s'appellent sa folle
de son spectacle s'appelle la traversée
du désir c'est du 3 au 8 et qu'on voit
la taille de la toison pubienne ya pas
trop de cinq jours donc ça c'est le
spectacle nous pourrons c'est autre
chose
ah oui voila j'ai pris au hasard la
photo d'un comédien j'ai passé mon la
moins bien il a des belles dents
blanches alignées et tout mais si on lui
taillent les dents en pointe comme on
voit ici il est nettement moins bien il
est nettement moins bien pour nous parce
que s'il était si c'était un flic mais
il serait nettement mieux et on va voir
un sujet sur sûr ça qui était qui nous
était qu'on a pu faire grâce à monsieur
qui s'appelle alain epelboin qui est
médecin et ethnologue chercheur au cnrs
et les pygmées bmb dans pas comme nous
on va voir ça c'est l'histoire d'un
adolescent qui fument effet le pygmée
très à l'aise mais il n'est pas à l'aise
du tout mouais sa place je ne le saurai
pas non plus car un autre type aiguisant
un couteau sur un caillou l'adolescent
s'installe puisqu'il faut bien passer
par là pour séduire les filles l'autre
pygmées lui un sensibilise les gencives
puis lui taillent les dents chaque
incisif doit ressembler à une canine et
les canines doivent être encore plus
coupante question d'élégance un enfant
pygmées assistent au spectacle puis
s'enfuit en courant
vraiment pas pressé de grandir lui le
taillage des dents terminé l'adolescent
admire la belle ouvrage dans le
rétroviseur d'un camion dont on se
demande bien ce qu'il fout là le pygmée
se regarde pas vraiment c'est une belle
dentition de carnassiers les filles
seront contentes les filles aiment les
hommes au cros de fauves c'est donc si
important de se faire tailler les dents
comme ça bises et et oui nous nous c'est
le contraire comme un piano est oui oui
d'ailleurs c'est pas remboursé avec une
fois franck sinatra fait une farce il
était une réception et il a enlevé son
dentier et sa perruque
il a dit alors admirer mois maintenant
et mais moi continue à me voilà bien on
vous a demandé un petit coup de colère
quelque chose qui vous a dérangé depuis
depuis cette semaine ou la semaine
d'avant peu importe un coup de colère
particulier est très récent ou essai
c'est selon les déclarations de notre
ancien président de la république
qui est un homme d'intelligence qui est
un homme de wii qui est un homme qui est
en période électorale qui voudrait bien
devenir président de la république qui a
parlé d'un d'une question extrêmement
douloureuse
je pense surtout pour ceux qui sont
immigrées plus que pour ceux qui sont
envahi mon choix c'est une question très
délicate et très très sérieuse
valéry giscard d'estaing qui parlait
donc de l'invasion encore la base il n'a
pas pris il ya pas les deux choses il a
parlé d' invasion il a parlé de sang oui
vous m'avez parlé d'un autre coup de
colère nous on était sur cette scène de
37,2 qui vous avait dérangé c'est
jusqu'à destin qui a tourné dans 37 2
avec béatrice dalle avec béatrice dalle
mettez vous allez voir ça va aller très
vite les secrets parce que sur votre
coup de colère si vous voulez vous faire
quoi non j'aime bien beineix le metteur
en scène il ya une chose que je ne
supporte pas c'est l'état l'âge de
viande est ce que de la femme sur les
écrans vous allez déjà tourné quand même
avec des femmes nues à vos côtés avec
qui vous avez pu tourner les scènes
d'amour la gêne et bouffe chez pai amis
lui ont mené la grande bouffe et est un
film à la gloire de la femme
contrairement à ce qu'on pense
et c'était un film destructeur pour le
comportement des hommes
mais qu'est ce qui me gène le fait qu'on
utilise et comédienne qu'on est cons et
qu'on l'aimé
non je le déshabille souvent parce que
les comédiens s'y mettent aussi
maintenant oui ça dépend avec qui ose
des abris non c'est comme dans la vie ça
vous avez vous êtes déjà demandé de
tourner nue
oui oui je les fais parce que moi je
suis un pudique mais j'ai tourné nue
mais j'étais comme une statue je vous
dis ça avait un sens l'iso psychologique
savez un récent traumatique mais je
déteste l'état l'âge de la femme
manipuler comme ça et je trouve que
c'est c'est de la misogynie et non pas
de là c'est pas la gloire de la femme
alors que le cinéma a toujours été à la
gloire de la femme générer toutes les
actrices qui donc avait rêvé se débite
déshabiller mais d'une façon extrêmement
délicate
rita hayworth a enlevé un long gant noir
s'est esquissée la scène la plus sexy de
tous bords marlène dietrich montrer un
peu jarretelles on en rêve encore ou
ceux qui n'ont pas vu arriveront demain
donc je leur pourrez voir et allez voir
c'est marlène dietrich se déshabiller
bonjour la semaine prochaine il faudrait
que les téléspectateurs nous envoie des
histoires d'amour à ce n'est attendre
d'abord il faut que je me dise et 2
phrase à méditer
non c'est très facile alors le faire une
petite devinette
je vais vous dire deux phrases qui
concerne l'amour une haie de
schopenhauer et l'autre de patrick bruel
est ce qu'il faut savoir c'est 2 qui est
la phrase de patrick elles sont déjà
toutes en train de se réduire parce
qu'on a prononcé le mot de patrick brûlé
alors première fois je vous dis pas qui
c'est l'amour est une illusion pour
perpétuer la race deuxième phrase pas
compte quand on aime on aime quand on
aime et qu'on est aimé c'est formidable
qu'on soit connu ou pas connu l'amour
c'est plus fort que tout quand c'est pas
plus fort que tout ce n'est pas de
l'amour que dans laquelle patrick bruel
deuxième barrière si vous croisez ça on
peut pas vous entendre un bon passage de
la deuxième
ça devait trop je peux faire
la phrase de patrick bruel à celle de l
éthique que les frais triste cette
gauche au piano vers l'amour est une
illusion pour perpétuer la race dire que
la définition de l'amour ça pourrait
être quoi je ne saurais pas vous de leur
sel définition et je crois que si je me
mets à table est pour écrire des
définitions
je ne serai pas fait une définition de
l'amour ce qui est beau jeu tout en
amour c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
définition qui s'est dit me devais de
l'hymne national c'est l'irrationnel
c'est là palpable pas toujours
vous avez eu des rencontres amoureuses
insolite spectaculaire il vous arrive
dans l'avion j'ai pas dans les aéroports
de de trouver les femmes seraient de
passage
ça arrive à tout le monde oui ça m'est
arrivé mais dans l'avion nous dans
l'avion je suis toujours conduit est
dans le trou en voyage ou non dans les
noms dans le train
monsieur piccoli ce qu'on cherche c'est
des histoires d'amour c'est la première
émission et on voudrait y est important
non mais vous connaissez peut-être des
gens nous ce qu'on voudrait c'est que
dès les gens qui nous regardent nous
écrivent et nous racontent leur histoire
d'amour
alors soit ils se servent du minitel
étape 36 15 fr pour un code à vos amours
ou bien il nous écrive à à vos amours
202 rue de la croix nivert 75015 paris
voilà on va parler de la passion de
michel piccoli dont quelques petits
instants qu'est ce qui t'arrive t bag à
dos et nous raconte pas comment ces
rencontres et ça vous intéresse oui vous
voulez qu'on fasse une petite mise en
scène
vous savez on peut se lever ça s'est
passé comme ça bon tu on est sur une
plage jean marty dit ok voilà moi je
suis l aile et courrait nu sur la plage
et courrait nu sur la plage moi je suis
arrivé sur un cheval que vous m'aviez
prêter oui je les attrape est comme ça
oui je les ai emmenés et puis et puis le
cheval est devenu un hip hop quand on
est arrivés en france et puis voilà et
voilà aller gratter merci au revoir on
passe tout de suite à la passion de
michel piccoli
[Musique]
bien michel piccoli la passion vous êtes
un passionné de nature vous ne concevez
les rapports amoureux que travers cette
passion elle est toujours réelle
aujourd'hui
absolument je suis né écologique
écologistes et la tendresse la tendresse
en amour capitale attire plus de passion
j'ai pu y a plus rien non mais
latendresse peut exister même quand il
ya patients même quand il ya coup de
foudre généré même cotia extravagance
oui bien sûr ça marche comme ça oui ça
doit marcher comme ça la passion en tout
cas professionnel c'est votre métier
on le sait en plus vous êtes très
dynamique en ce moment vous avez quatre
films à trois films à l'affiché soit
vous l'aimez 4e art dans oui monsieur
bon si vous voulez on va on va appeler
ça comme ça vous n'êtes pas dans la
belle noiseuse un film magnifique vous
êtes savant dans martin et moi la bijoux
vous êtes bientôt parce que c'est pas
sur les écrans une coproduction fr3 dont
l'une de papatakis les équilibristes
vous serez un écrivain homosexuels
amoureux d'un ramasseur de crottes à
vrai dire ça comme ça et vous êtes en ce
moment sur les écrans dans le voleur
d'enfants aux côtés de marchiennes aux
martys ryan vous êtes illusionniste et
vous êtes comme ça on regarde un extrait
on en discute après
les beaux à regarder le jeu du premier
set
cette sensibilité pourquoi pas mais
comme ça et je rappelle que nous en tant
que n'at-on pas sénégal ics délicate qui
pourrait se passer si jouer à côté
petits secrets
je vous ai pas encore présenté la halle
aux candidats un genre des murs mandat
mais des artistes nice tôt sally
fabriqués par nos grands robert-houdin
lunel il ya eu un petit accident j'ai un
père et il se porte comme un charme on
remarque n'est plus ici tetris est
magnifique ça vient ça vient mais un
mois chaque fois mais oui il ya le 18
mars et du bras avant qu'une semaine
[Musique]
on
oh
annie trimestre c'est quelqu'un que vous
aimez particulièrement fait une émission
sur l'amour mastroianni vous dites c'est
pour pour quelqu'un de mon âge c'est
quelqu'un de gai les gens de mon âge
sont souvent triste oui plus on prend de
l'âge eu plus quelquefois on s'est
assoupi au devient triste ou devient
inquiet on peut être à quai à 18 heures
mais on était inquiet de ce qui est
passé on est inquiet de du peu de temps
qui reste
mais marcello et moi nous faisons partie
de ces éternels enfants comédiens auquel
l'âge ne nous a pas encore accablé de
ses angoisses
c'est un film de christian de chalonge
d'après sibérienne le bon que ça se fait
ça pendant quelques instants je ne suis
pas prête
je voulais juste vous dire vous dites on
veut de prendre toujours dans dans les
films comme c'est souvent des rôles de
séducteurs de possesseurs j'ai envie
d'être un amuseur vous l'êtes dans
l'illusionniste
absolument mais on peut être possesseur
et amusèrent c'est le comble du bonheur
est absolument ça rime le gambien notre
coup non alors oui d'accord je vais vous
faire toucher notre petite question
c'est la dernière ces supplices
on est bien celle du milieu on ne sait
pas pour des rosses errance tripoli
racontez-nous un fantasme le public a
dur à trouver un fantasme
je me demande si j'ai pas la chance
d'avoir j'ai eu le bonheur de réaliser
des fantasmes et je ne veux pas dire que
j'étais un peu comblé par des fantasmes
dans mes rapports avec les personnes
j'ai un fantasme c'est très personnel
mais dès qu'on parle fantasme on
s'imagine à l'amour à la perversité on y
revient donc y avoir des fantasmes dans
dans les idéaux des fantasmes dans les
rapports quotidiens des fantasmes dans
les rêves et s'il y en avait qu'un ce
serait de 2 un jour peut-être bien que
je n'y crois pas c'est retrouver mon
frère qui est mort avant ma naissance et
grâce auquel je suis en vie vous êtes né
parce que ce frère est mort et que du
complète je suis né d'un frère mort
peut-être encore plus que de ma mère et
de mon père c'est un fantasme bien sûr
merci en tout cas nous avoir fait
partager
on va parler maintenant d'une de vos
passions que les téléspectateurs ne
connaissent pas spécifiquement vous êtes
un fou amoureux des chevaux
on va d'abord vous voir à l'oeuvre je
sais pas si vous mentez vous montez pas
cheval là mais voulait pas risquer je
n'ai pas osé monter sur les shows de
zingaro
non elle va vous retrouver là-bas j'ai
du garrot bonjour bienvenue chez easy
l'euro est notre invité aujourd'hui
c'est michel piccoli
[Musique]
il paraît même que michel c'est très
bien s'occuper des chevaux et qu'il
aurait un diplôme les cas diplôme dans
ma vie je suis quand même assez fier
c'est le diplôme d'aptitude de bons
soigneur pour chevaux aux amulettes ça
signifie qu'on sait penser des shows et
qu'on sait s'occuper des chevaux qu'on
s'est fait à l'aller il ya des chevaux
que pour se soigner les shows une chose
que j'aime c'est pas tellement monté à
cheval mais bon je suis pas un grand
cavalier du tout mais c'est de m'occuper
du cheval de sentir le fumier de laver
et de nettoyer des de prendre l'épongé
du nettoyage et les naseaux les yeux et
le cul mais dites moi je lis qu'on vous
a vu dans des films je vous le changez
fun autant comme un peu j'ai jamais
tollé de west ham mais j'ai cherché d'un
muffin catonné massette duval du don
juan de molière il votre amour des sous
ça date de quand exactement
je crois que ça date de dunes et
proposer des petits garçons j'avais rêvé
fermiers dans l'oise et c'était l'époque
où les chevaux faisait de la bourse il
évoque encore le chou travailler la
terre
[Musique]
je lui là
c'est gentil de nous avoir emmenés chez
zynga rocher le grand bartabas pourquoi
est ce que vous aimez un garrot on croit
que d'une gare au total cirque s'appelle
opéra caisse en fait il ne fait pas
comme dans les cirques où il ya les
clips de travail de chevaux admirable
mais très mécanisée
tandis que là il réussit à travailler le
cheval et en même temps à le laisser une
liberté et une invention et la fameux
chevalier noir de ce que fut son nom et
il réussit à le faire rire et a fait
rire le public avec un cheval qui fait
le clown cavalier cheval
voilà voilà en tout cas michel piccoli
c'est pas étonnant cette passion du
cheval vous êtes un amoureux de la terre
vous en avez besoin c'est viscéral
oui je vais été un très bon homme de la
terre un très bon agriculteurs n'ont
rien pu changer de métier trop tard et
le cheval vous en possédez des chevaux
oui comme vous savez posséder des
chevaux quand audio il possède à cheval
mon dieu non mais sa véritable amour ce
que je veux dire c'est une version de la
vidéo que très différentes façons de
posséder un cheval on peut piocher un
cheval soit disant quelconque qui était
à cheval admirable et on peut posséder
des chevaux qui valent des milliards
sont deux mondes tout à fait différent
vous ce sont des milliards des pur sang
ou sonorités dechorgnat non ce sont des
purs sang mais que j'ai sauvée de la
boucherie donc il ne valait plus rien
sur le papier sur le prix on m'a dit
vous avez appris à monter à cheval à la
dure avec un morceau paille cuincy entre
votre cuisse et le cheval par le cuissot
autres avant tout la tension entre le
genou je nous ai milité à vous et
apprenez moto cheval il mettait une
paille
et si la paille tombait en fait un coup
de cravache ou lula là nous pas le
cheval j'ai bien compris ça s'appelle à
la dure bien ça vous a plu cette
émission sur l'amour oui je trouve que
c'était très court oui c'est important
j'ai eu un clin d'oeil de je ne sais pas
qui avait l'air de dire vite vite vite
vite
je voulais vous demander une définition
de l'amour j'ai retrouvé une ancienne
définition vous dites c'est l'amour la
définition d'amour picaudière vous dites
données à celles qu'on aime la vie
qu'elle a rêvé d'avoir pendant son
enfance c'était votre définition à
l'époque oui c'est une bonne définition
je crois surtout que si on est vraiment
en amour il faut aussi aimer la vie de
l'autre même si l'autre a eu comme on
dit une vie a eu à passer vous allez
continuer à croire que les passes et
sont tout aussi passionnant que le
présent vous allez continuer à
rechercher dans votre vie l'ambiguïté
toujours la provocation toujours dérangé
dire ce que vous pensez toujours et je
suis au service des autres pour qu'ils
fassent la même chose avec moi bien
notre prochaine invitée dimanche ça sera
bernard giraudeau j'espère que vous
l'aimez vous avez à vous justifier par
rapport à ça nous avons tourné ensemble
oui nous sommes des copains très bien ce
qu'il est dit quelque chose de très
gentil il dit que vous êtes au service
du personnage vous rester dans les
limites de ce dont le rôle a besoin et
vous avez le talent de n'être pas plus
intelligent que le metteur en scène par
rapport au film merci bernard picoler
d'avoir fait cette émission
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]